mr. Mackenzie told us that mr. Brown
spoke to you on the phone this was on or
shortly after the 30th of September 2009
and he mr. Brown is said to have roared
at you for 20 minutes is that true or
not I'm afraid that I'm very happy to
tell you about the conversation that mr.
Mackenzie him and I might have talked
about occasionally seemed there was a
very colorful exaggeration mr. Brown did
call me and said Rupert who do you know
what's going on here and I said what do
you mean he said well the Sun and what
it's doing and how it came out and I
said I'm not aware of the I was not
warned the exact timing I'm not aware of
what they're saying I'm a long one on
the way away but I'm sorry to tell you
Gordon we have come to a conclusion that
we will support a change of government
when and if there's an election he said
and I must stress no voices were raised
we were talking more quietly than you
and I are now the he said well your path
your company has made declared war on my
government and we have no alternative
but to make war on your company and I
said I'm sorry about that Gordon thank
you for calling end of subject
how could mr. Brown have declared war on
your company
I don't know the I don't think even in a
very bad state of mind